hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Sydney shark the sequel
to Miami shark there's really no
explanation that I could possibly give
it's it is it seemed about shark so
let's get to it
Irish I'm a shark ah this is exactly all
I get a do an amateur
uh oh and there's like a slightly
improved version but in all honesty I
don't know exactly how it would be
improved because the first game was so
unbelievable who I need that in my mouth
submarine okay william shark that makes
sense
alright cool why hundred what those poor
people observing the wonderful coast of
Australia it's so beautiful didn't they
know that everything in what washes by
horses
what's a horrible it's so horrible
sooo confused where the Ducks can I eat
those bastards because apparently those
guys actually deserve it oh really
ah
oh my plane more like my plane boom
those actually the name of it yeah
all right then for Steve urban urban
Herman burger
thank you it's a shark get that shot
buddy you're gonna get underwater shot
hope you have water boy
the oceanfront is also noticing who
there might be oh god I don't know what
I'm more concerned about the horse or
those poor skydivers it's a horrible
everything is going wrong Beluga that's
a beluga off that's just a big plane
actually explodes every single time I
can eat the underwater things where are
the Ducks
give me that good give me the goddamn
ducks
whoa I'll leave that one I'll leave that
one yeah I'm sorry I just killed your
friends apparently Tasha horrible mother
play my blade horrible horrible game
give me yes you it's okay he lured it
okay bye
well they didn't take their lumps like a
man I don't feel bad at all anymore cuz
Sharkey do it show you one mammoth
thumbs can turn come here you oh and
hang-glider more like ocean glider aw
damn 59 minutes ago I'm running out of
shark jokes there's so much things I can
say when I'm eating absolutely
everything in the entire Sydney area
I'm pretty sure I'm the dumbest I'm
pretty sure I'm Devin I'm pretty sure
I'm devastating the entire population
sitting right now Australian fans is
this what you have to actually deal with
on a day-to-day basis made basis why is
there kangaroo in that play I don't
understand uh say at all I just asked
Ross if there's anything any way if
you're to what he kills the goodreads
anyone he wasn't no I just want to be
with them hey I've got cool sunglasses
hey how did he go in there you're so
cute and adorable I would never hurt you
I might hurt everyone else here but I
never you know a shark
what's a lien oh yeah I don't want
article wait this for the ocean hold
tentacles I'm not actually bothered by
that I was just returning to Italy oh
that seems I'm doing a good thing I'm
doing a good thing yeah dad
okay that was Wow that was Sydney shucks
it was so much more intense than Miami
shark but also still really cool so I
highly recommend playing this game for
yourself please do play let me know if
you play it let me know if you have just
as much fun and let me know if you beat
my score thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
and you can't be safer
I love feeling leather on my test I'm
some fun this beat is bit walking a ride
on your disco stick